العام لمجلس الامن القوميه الاوكرانيه
اليكسي قال ان اوكرانيا مستعده لاطلاق
هجومها المضاد فيما قالت نائبته وزير
الدفاع ان القوات الروسيه تنفذ عملا
هجوميه في سته اتجاهات ويتم التصدي لها من
جهه اخرى اكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
المعارك في محاور
باخموتا شرقيه البلاد ما تزال مستمره
هذا وقالت هيئه الاركان انها سجلت 25
اشتباكا مع القوات الروسيه خلال الساعه
الاخيره كما وصفت الهجمات الروسيه على
ضواحي باخوت بال فاشله معلنه صدى هجمات
على مدينتيكا ومارينكا
ينضم الينا من
مراسله الجزيره تامر راس ماضي ومن
دانياسكا مراسله الجزيره
لو بدانا اولا مع تامر الصمادي ماذا تقول
اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق
بالهجمات التي تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بانها نفذتها هذا اليوم في اثنين وثمانين
موقعا وانها اوقعت المئات من القتلى
الاوكرانيين
بالفعل الجمال السلطات الاوكرانيه عسكريا
سياسيا لا تعلق على البيانات الصادره عن
الجانب الروسي لا سيما المتعلقه
بالخسائر في صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه لكن
اليوم الحديث الاوكراني ينصب ويركز على
شيء مهم وواحد لا ثاني له وهو الحديث
الخاص بالهجوم المضاد اليوم
ظهر قائد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في
تسجيل المصور في احدى ميادين القتال مع
عدد من القوات الاوكرانيه والى جانبه
العديد من المدرعات والاليات ونشر هذا
المقطع المصور على صفحته في التليجرام
وكتب
معلقا عليه بان بانه قد حان الاوان لتحرير
الاراضي الاوكرانيه كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من القوات الروسيه والحديث هنا
عن الدومباس وما تبقى من زبالوجيا وخيرسون
بالاضافه الى شبه جزيره القرم التي تضعها
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في سلم
الاولويات فيما يخص الهجوم المضاد
ظهر امين عام مجلس الامن القومي الاوكراني
ليقول بان اوكرانيا
استنفذت كامل الاجراءات او فرغت من كامل
الاجراءات الخاصه بهذا الهجوم وان القوات
الاوكرانيه باتت جاهزه للبدء بتنفيذ هذا
الهجوم على اكثر من محور على اكثر من جبهه
لكن ايضا القصف تواصل في المقابل القصف
الروسي تواصل على المقاطعات الجنوبيه وحتى
الشرقيه منها قبل قليل اعلنت السلطات
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في خاركف عن
تجدد القصف الروسي على منطقه خاركيف وعلى
العديد من القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خط
التماس بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
وهنا في ميكولا يتحدث عمده المقاطعه عن
اسقاط مسيرتين هجوميتين في قلب المدينه في
سماء المدينه والحديث عن استمرار القصف
المكثف على المناطق الساحليه في ميكولايب
وغير بعيد عن ذلك حيث خيرسون القصف ايضا
تواصل حاكم المقاطعه الاوكراني تحدث عن
استهداف البنيه التحت الخطوط الماء خطوط
الكهرباء بالاضافه الى عديد المناطق
الماهوله بالسكان تحدث عن قتيلين في صفوف
المدنيين بالاضافه الى عدد من الجرحى وفي
زبروجيا ايضا الحديث عن اكثر من 100 هجوم
على طول القرى الواقعه على خط التماس بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه في المقابل
تتحدث قياده عمليات الجنوب عن قيامها
بهجمات متواصله على مواقع تمركز القوات
الروسيه في خرسون وزبروجيا الحديث عن
توكناك
والحديث عن خسائر في صفوف القوات الروسيه
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب تحدثت
عن عشرات القتلى اليوم في صفوف القوات
الروسيه بالاضافه الى تدمير عدد كبير من
الاليات والمدرعات وفي ضوء كل ذلك يتواصل
القتال على محاور الشرق لاسيما ابديفكا
ومارينكا وباخمت خرجت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني خلال الساعات الماضيه وتحدثت عن
سته جبهات يجري القتال عليها بين القوات
الاوكر انيه والروسيه وقالت بان القوات
الاوكرانيه مازالت تسيطر على جزء من داخل
المدينه الحديث عن جنوب غربت وان القتال
يتواصل على محاور المدينه وضواحيها نعم
شكرا جزيلا